a lot has happened since russia decided
to invade the ukraine on february 24th
thursday of last week since then there
have been over 200 civilian casualties
and around 60 to 70 deaths in ukraine
alone but ukraine is not going quietly
they have been fighting for days and
almost a week now to try to prove that
they are an independent country who will
not stand to be invaded by russia but
now ukraine is standing up again they
are offering russian soldiers 5 million
rupees in crypto or cash to surrender
let me say it again they're offering
russian soldiers over 5 million rupees
in cash or crypto to surrender both with
or without their military equipment so
that 5 million rupees is worth around 50
000
that is a lot of money ukraine's
ministry of defense is quoted saying
decided to give money to russian
soldiers if they surrender with their
weapons they can also receive this fee
in their accounts in cash or in crypto
payments will be made immediately and
the soldiers will be released after they
appear in court that after they appear
appear in court is very very key here
because not only will they receive the 5
million rupos worth around that 50 000
usd but they will also receive amnesty
after they appear in court for all their
unlawful crimes that they are committing
by invading the ukraine they are
unlawfully invading another country's
territory at the direction of the
russian federation and the russian
military but if they decide to go ahead
and surrender with or without their
military weapons they will receive not
only 5 million rupees in cash or in
crypto but they will also receive
amnesty in the country of ukraine this
will be interesting to see how it plays
out i'm not a geopolitical expert i
don't think a lot of people are everyone
has their own opinions do your own
research but i stand up with the people
of ukraine and i hope that they continue
to fight for their freedom and
ultimately get it hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time